What is your best day ever?
Go roller skating, I love roller skating.
Riding a giraffe with monkeys.
Driving a Ferrari.
First I'd do a couple, like, five or six arcade games,...
...and I might even want to find new animals.
I'll go to my grandma's with my monkeys and my giraffe...
...and ride on the roof with it.
Going to the moon,...
...and maybe some other planets?
Yeah, awesome day.
Every year we invite students from kindergarten through 12th grade...
...to create their own doodle based on our logo.
This year's Doodle 4 Google theme is: "My best day ever."
It's easy to enter; just go to the Doodle 4 Google website,...
...download the application and get doodling!
You can mail in entries or upload them directly to the site.
The winning doodle will be featured on the Google home page...
...for millions of people to enjoy.
So, what's your young artist's best day ever?
We can't wait to find out.